[MUSIC PLAYING]
[VOCALIZING WITH MUSIC]
SPEAKER 1: This week's
cool things of the week
comes from all of our hosts.
For those of you
who don't know, this
is Mark's final
episode on the podcast.
And the new hosts came
together to show our gratitude
to Mark and all of
his efforts to make
the podcast as impactful
as it is for our listeners.
So without further ado,
here are some kind words
that we'd all like to share.
SPEAKER 2: 200 episodes,
if you do the math,
I'm pretty sure that's
just about four years
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
And none of that would have
been possible without Mark
not only coming up
with this great idea,
but being there,
entertaining people,
teaching people, giving
them learning moments.
Thank you so much, Mark, for
this awesome opportunity,
and I know that all of
the hosts that we have now
are super excited
to carry this on.
Thanks again, Mark.
SPEAKER 3: On this, our
founder's very last episode,
I want to express my gratitude
for his contributions
to the show.
Mark's vision, expertise,
and boundless enthusiasm
have shaped our content and
helped us all grow as hosts.
Let's take the time to show
our appreciation for all
of our past hosts,
Francesc, for conceiving
of the idea with Mark and
seeing it come to fruition;
Melanie, for leveling up content
with a heavy dose of machine
learning and the
ability to convince
the most fascinating
people that they should
talk to her on the record.
I'm still amazed at the
guests we've had on the show.
And that's all thanks to
their hard work and glittering
personalities.
Thank you, Melanie,
Mark, and Francesc.
The show will never be the same.
SPEAKER 4: I remember
listening to the podcast
before joining Google,
and I never imagined
that I'd join on as a host.
I remember when
Melanie asked if I'd
like to join at breakfast
over a year ago.
So sorry, Mark, I can't give you
the credit for bringing me on.
But you definitely helped me
and the rest of our other hosts
get up to speed to
fill your shoes.
We're 200 episodes in, and
the podcast is still kicking,
and that's thanks to
you, Mark, as well as
Melanie and Francesc.
I'm sure I speak for
our weekly listeners
when I say thank you for
creating this platform,
bringing on weekly
interesting guests,
and giving us a healthy dose
of you in every episode.
So enjoy podcast retirement.
And we'll be looking
forward to having you
on as a special guest or a host.
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: So
very excited today
to be joined by Bjorn Lindberg,
online technical director
here at Massive Entertainment.
How are you doing, Bjorn?
BJORN LINDBERG: I'm doing fine.
Thank you.
It's morning.
My voice haven't warmed up yet.
But that's fine.
It's going to get going now.
MARK MANDEL: That's excellent.
BJORN LINDBERG: You
guys forced me to speak.
I mean, this don't
happen before lunch.
MARK MANDEL: That's
good, excellent.
We actually have a guest host
here today, Robert Martin.
Robert, you want to say
hi and just tell people
who you are here at Google?
ROBERT MARTIN: Yeah.
Thanks, Mark.
I'm the global solutions
lead for cloud gaming
at Google Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
So Bjorn, this is all about you.
Tell us a little about yourself.
What do you do here at Massive?
BJORN LINDBERG: Yeah, I work as
an online technical director,
which basically means glorified
programming, pretty much.
So I'm trying to program.
That's my main focus.
That's why I'm here.
And that's my interest, really.
But as things turn out,
organizational reasons,
you want someone that
sits there and say
yes or no to certain things.
And generally speaking, I
don't want to say yes or no,
but sometimes you need
to make decisions.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
No, that makes a lot of sense.
So tell us a little bit
about Massive Entertainment,
because some people
may not be familiar.
BJORN LINDBERG: Yeah, so we
are basically a triple-A gaming
studio.
We are in Sweden.
We are fully owned
by Ubisoft, which
is a big French company
that owns a bunch of studios
and a bunch of employees.
And currently we
have been working
on two "Division" games.
So we just released
"Division 2" this March.
And there are big online
shooters, PVP, co-op looter
shooter, get all the gear,
build your character,
endless progression kind
of thing, all this online,
all the players.
ROBERT MARTIN: Yeah,
so tell us a little bit
about "Division 2," sort of the
newest iteration of "Division."
What were players most
excited about for this title?
BJORN LINDBERG: Purely
from my perspective,
there's a whole lot of features
in the game I could talk about.
This is not my area.
But purely from my
perspective, it's
kind of the same thing just
did better, less problems
and smoother, nicer experience.
Then, of course, if
you look at the game,
there's a bunch of new features.
And you can do all these things.
And there's new content,
et cetera, right?
But from my
perspective, it's a lot
of do the thing we did
for the first game,
just do it better, less problems
for the players, basically.
That's where we want to land.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And you work primarily on the
multi-player back-end services
side of things.
Is that right?
BJORN LINDBERG:
Yeah, pretty much.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
BJORN LINDBERG: I used to say my
job is, like get players online
and get them to play with
other players if they want to.
Or they can play
themselves if you want to.
That's your choice,
basically, as a player.
But you shouldn't be like a big
hurdle going online and finding
a friend.
You don't want to run through
enormous amounts matchmaking
lobbies just to
play five minutes
and then sit in matchmaking
lobbies for another 20 minutes
to get to play five minutes
and that kind of stuff.
You just want it to be
smooth, generally speaking.
You want to go press
a button, say, I
want to play with other players
while I'm doing something.
And eventually we find you
some players to play with.
And you say, yes,
and then you get
teleported to where you want
to be, and there you go.
MARK MANDEL: No, that
makes a lot of sense.
ROBERT MARTIN: So you
mentioned it's a single-player
or a multi-player game.
How important would you
say for a game like this
the multi-player aspect is?
BJORN LINDBERG: The way you
should think about it, I think,
is this.
Most players approach
games like, oh, I
can play a team player.
I can play it myself, right?
At some point, they're going
to say, well, this was fun,
but maybe it's fun if I play
with my friends, for instance.
And then you can
form a co-op group
and play together against
the environment, so to speak,
and all that AI whatever, right?
You don't want that stuff
to be too large for players
to build the group
with their friends.
Eventually someone's
going to say, oh, well,
there's none of my
friends online today.
I'm going to play
with random people.
I want a pick up
group, like match-make,
to get into group with players.
Same thing there, you don't want
it to be a large step forward.
And eventually you
end up in this sense
where it's like some players
are going to go to PVP gaming,
where they play
against other players.
And in a way, that's
the perpetual game,
where it just goes on forever
and ever because the content is
other players, in a way.
That sounds weird,
but it's really--
at some point, you're
going to run out
of things to do essentially.
So you want to play
against other players.
We know from experience
that not everyone
is going to end up in
PVP because it's like,
me, for instance,
I never go there.
I don't like to
fight other people.
I'm a teamwork guy.
I want to play with
other players not
against other players.
So it's kind of your choice.
But we don't want it to force
you into that thing, right?
So the importance here
is that it's available.
But you can still enjoy the
game as a single-player player,
if you would want to.
And there's no hard line
that you need to, like,
go press a bunch of buttons
in a UI and get there,
and it's complicated long
waiting times and that stuff.
MARK MANDEL: I hear the
launch went really well.
But can you give us
a sense of the scale
of the game or how many
players or anything
along those sort of lines?
BJORN LINDBERG: The
problem with online games
is that you've
released your game,
and then everyone comes at
that launch pretty much, right?
And when I say at
launch, I mean usually
during a couple of weeks.
It takes a couple
of days for people
to pick it up in all the
regions around the world
and stuff like that.
But usually the first
and second weekend
is going to be a
whole lot of players.
And if you compare this to,
say, I make my own website,
I invite my friends to
test my new photo sharing,
whatever it is, right, then
maybe 10 guys in the beginning,
and you figure out
a bunch of the bugs
and then word of mouth.
And two years in, you have
your 10 million daily users
or something like that.
You have fixed most of the
technical problems that
could happen to that point.
We can do scaling.
It's not that big of a deal.
We have kind of
the problem, where
we need to do scale they want.
And we don't really
have a choice.
So to scale here,
it's coming down to
basically having, A, all
the computability resources,
so to speak.
Like, you have all the machines
that you would ever need
and also making sure that
everything works together.
Because even if you
have all the machines,
it doesn't necessarily mean
all the intercommunication that
happens in the back end is
just available or working.
So
A lot of testing,
obviously, leads up
to this point where
you say, OK, let's
test this thing specifically
and see what it does.
And then you try to
separate as much as possible
in the code base
so you don't end up
in cases where
things are weirdly
inter-depending on each
other in a way where
weird stuff happens, basically.
Because testing a
whole system with all
these machines is very hard.
But simulating one million
real players, for instance,
is not something easy
to do because you
need to have all these
connections coming
from somewhere, et cetera.
MARK MANDEL: There's
no service where
you can just ask a million
of your closest friends?
BJORN LINDBERG: No.
Maybe we can certainly
[INAUDIBLE] a million
employees.
[INAUDIBLE] game
and say, go play.
That's not the case.
ROBERT MARTIN: So
the scale challenge
really comes in at
launch because there's
a bit of an unknown with
how many players are going
to show up on that
first day and where
it's going to go from there?
BJORN LINDBERG: Well, we
have a reasonable clue.
But still the system as a
whole is complex, right?
It's simple parts that make
complex behaviors together.
And we can test individual
parts and say, well,
I'm going to assume
that we're going
to see x amount of
requests per second
on this particular service.
And I'll test it for 10 times
as much and see that it works.
That I can do it
relatively easily.
But it doesn't mean
that it doesn't
have some weird
global side effect
in some other part of the
system that you didn't
think about or something.
It can be configuration
errors that
are hard to track down because
there's just so much of it.
ROBERT MARTIN: So
that's interesting.
You mentioned the
different components.
What are some of the
different components
that it takes to run a
multi-player game like this
on the cloud?
BJORN LINDBERG: I mean, we're
microservice architecture.
It's the easiest way to
get around this hurdle.
You want to have a
divide-and-conquer strategy
and say, OK, you guys,
you do matchmaking.
You guys, you do plans.
You guys, you do log-in, et
cetera, that kind of stuff,
right?
And [INAUDIBLE]
services basically we
have a common platform.
Everything works, so obviously,
because otherwise there
would be too much different
technologies in the space.
But supposedly we have
a bunch of services.
And some of them are essential
to get into the game.
Like, you need to
be able to log in.
You need to be able to find
a game server, et cetera.
Those things are tested
to death basically.
You want that flow to work.
However, if you have
some other service,
like, I don't know,
say, leaderboards,
and it has a hiccup
or five minutes,
it's not the end of the world.
And then you can focus resources
on things that are essential.
And then other things--
if the leaderboard
service crashes,
it's not going to tear
down the entire system.
That's the benefit
of microservices.
But it's also an
organizational benefit
because these guys can work
on their own, so to speak.
You don't have to
synchronize everything
with everyone else
that works online.
MARK MANDEL: Now, you also
mentioned game servers?
BJORN LINDBERG: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: What
does that control?
BJORN LINDBERG: So what
I'm doing generally
is getting people
to a game server.
That's my goal, basically.
Get them as smooth as
possible to a games server.
And once we get them
to a game server,
it's a whole different area.
We have a bunch of
teams, obviously.
But organizational
wise, in this case,
we are the online back-end
team that does everything
by orchestration and having
all the service available,
et cetera, working with our
infra guys that basically fix
the hardware, the virtual
hardware from Google,
to basically make sure
that's up and running.
But then we have
the gameplay team.
And they do the game
client and the game server.
So in the game server,
we do portions of it.
Like, we provide network
stack and libraries
for that kind of stuff.
But they do all
the gameplay logic.
And then if you compare
the relative complexity
of these two
things, like, if you
take all the online back end and
compare it to the games server,
the game server's
still more complicated
because it can do
so many things.
You have all these messages
for different things
you want to do.
I want to fix something
in my inventory.
I want to press the button.
I want to shoot that guy.
I want to move here.
I want to do all these things.
And to share interaction
of all these things
is going to make it very hard
to test properly and have
100% coverage on every single
case of everything, obviously.
So maybe I should
answer your question
of what the game server
does is basically running
the game simulation for you.
And the client will send these
orders to the game server.
They're picked up
on a frame basis.
So the game server
runs on frames,
process all that stuff for
your output, output should be,
and send it back to the player
and then do the next frame.
And it runs like that forever.
ROBERT MARTIN: So if I'm
playing a game of "Division 2"
with a few of my friends, we
all connect to a game server.
That's our simulated world
that we share gather.
BJORN LINDBERG: Yep.
It runs AI and knows what the
general layout of the world
is to a certain fidelity.
Like, it knows, here's a wall.
It maybe doesn't know there's
a piece of trash on the ground,
but it knows that here's a
wall, and here's a bunch of AI
and that kind of stuff.
ROBERT MARTIN: So each
time you get a new group
of players that shows up
and wants to play the game,
we need an additional
game server.
BJORN LINDBERG: No.
It holds them together.
So for various reasons--
the first one is that it's
a resource problem, right?
You don't want a new
process every single time
because you need to boot it, and
it eats such a bunch of memory
just by loading, right?
You need to load in an entire
world to have all this static.
It's called static, dimension
static, like physics.
It houses whatever, right?
And that's quite expensive
because the game is essentially
a piece of Washington, DC,
quite large piece, by the way.
So you need to load
all that into memory.
But then you're adding
one player for that.
It's like 1 megabyte worth
of memory for a player.
But you load it up 10 gigabytes
of RAM just to host the world.
So you probably want to
add a bunch of players
to make it break even, kind of.
So we host something, between
depending on hardware,
we are like 800 to 1,000
players per server.
But for most part,
you don't see them
because you instantiate
copies of the world.
So when you go online,
you're going to see yourself,
and that's it.
If you watch your
friend, you're going
to put you into the same
instance of the world
as you have.
MARK MANDEL: So you
kind of multi-tenant it.
BJORN LINDBERG: The
gaming term is phases,
but it's kind of multi-tenant.
MARK MANDEL: So it sounds like
running those game servers
at scale is a tricky problem.
How do you do that
on Google Cloud?
BJORN LINDBERG: Yeah,
we're basically having
a bunch of compute instances.
So the way it kind of
work is that the client
is going to figure out which
data center it would prefer.
But when it goes
online, it's going
to ping every data center.
Which one is closest to me?
OK, this one.
I would like, I don't
know, Europe somewhere.
And in that data
center, we have a bunch
of game servers
running, basically.
And various computing centers
runs in binary, and that's it.
It's very simple.
The reason for that
is because if we
were to do this today, carte
blanche, nothing prior,
we would probably
go, I don't know.
Here's a bunch of interesting
products from the Google
catalog we could use.
However, we have been doing
this for 20 years or so.
And we have a
bunch of technology
that solves a bunch of
these problems already.
It's easier just to
re-employ it and say, OK.
MARK MANDEL: That makes sense.
And I guess, then,
once you want to scale,
it's a question of just
adding more GCE instances
as it goes up.
BJORN LINDBERG: Yep.
ROBERT MARTIN: So
the launch is usually
the trickiest part of a game.
Can you walk us through it?
And I believe that "Tom Clancy
Division 2" is your first sort
of Google Cloud launch.
BJORN LINDBERG: That's true.
ROBERT MARTIN: Can you walk
us through the experience
of launching a
game on the cloud?
You mentioned
different data centers.
Maybe give us an idea of
the scale of the deployment.
BJORN LINDBERG:
Deployment, I think we're
in nine different regions.
I think at launch we
were a little more.
I think we were about 11 or 12.
I don't remember.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, interesting.
BJORN LINDBERG: Some
of these regions
are basically just
more data capacity
because you guys want us to
scale between different data
center.
But they're both in,
like, American West Coast.
And there's literally
no difference
from a player's point of
view at this point, Later on,
you can scale down a
little bit because you
don't have the same concurrency
as you had when you launched.
Yeah, it's quite large.
But we try to automate almost
everything because there's
no one that's going to
sit there and say, start
another server and all that.
It usually happens 9:00
in the evening in Sweden
and then goes on until midnight.
And people want to be home.
So we want to automate.
And then you add the tons
of alarms for various things
that could happen.
And then you'd best
make sure that you
can fix it if it happens.
I think your question was,
if it was smooth or not?
Or--
ROBERT MARTIN: Yeah, just
interested in the experience
of launching a
game in the cloud.
BJORN LINDBERG: Yeah,
so my experience is it
was very smooth because we had
done it on physical hardware
before.
And generally speaking,
that's a little more work
because you need to
provision the hardware,
and you need to get to the
install, yada yada, all
those kinds of things
you need to do,
and you have someone there
running down in data center
and changing [INAUDIBLE]
or whatever it is, right?
And this time we learned APIs.
We run everything through
Salt and Terraform.
And it's up and running.
And we auto scale a bunch
of stuff into the cloud
as well, which you can do now.
So it's very convenient.
And you don't necessarily
bother too much about it.
I'm not the who's guy
sitting there doing
all the work in that
sense because I'm not
doing deployment so much.
But I got the impression
from the people doing it
that this is way easier,
less work for us,
and you can trust it to
actually work much more
than you could before.
It kind of makes
sense, in a way,
because you deploy a generic
interface, so to speak.
You don't care too much about
what we put them on and vice
versa, right?
So we don't talk too much about
what you're doing on your end.
From that perspective,
yeah, I think
it's a sensible approach to
do it like that because it's
easier for everyone involved.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
actually really interesting you
mentioned that you
started in 11 regions,
and then you sort
of scaled down.
Is that just because you
know your traffic better?
Is that why, sort of
like a cost savings?
BJORN LINDBERG:
Yeah, pretty much.
And in some cases,
like when we say
regions, what we
really mean is, like,
we don't mean South America.
We mean data centers.
And in some cases, as I said,
some of these data centers
are basically equivalent
of each other,
like their next
door geographically.
And from a player's
point of view,
it doesn't really matter if
you're on that one or that one.
They are both good, so to speak.
And the reason we spread out is
because you don't necessarily
know the capacity,
what's it going
to look like in 2 hours
or 15 hours or whatever
and say, OK, let's just be
everywhere, just to be safe.
And we don't know if you're
going to run out of resources
in a particular data center.
So it makes sense to pre-warm
one and have it ready to go,
if you need to.
MARK MANDEL: Actually, for
those who may not be aware,
can you talk a
little bit about why
you have to be in
so many regions
and what the latency
requirements are there?
BJORN LINDBERG: Game
servers, so what
happens is you run them at a
certain framework, in our case,
about 30 times a second,
20 to 40 times a second,
depending on what you're doing.
And you want to get that
message to the game server
within a reasonable time.
If it takes like
200 milliseconds
to get there and then the server
processing time, plus the trip
back, you add a half a second
behind all the time, right?
From when I press something,
it takes half a second
before my client can
acknowledge the effect, right?
If you have too
much latency, it's
going to be noticeable
at some point.
In particular, say, I'm
living in Australia.
And I have to connect to Europe.
It's going to be not incredibly
interesting to play that game.
So you want to be close to
the player for that reason.
Well, generally, what
we do, of course,
we hide a lot of this latency.
As an example, we can have
a guy, I'm in my scope.
Tiny scopes I have a couple
of degrees field of view.
And a guy runs
through the scope,
and I want to shoot them in
the head as he runs by me.
I'm going to allow my client to
say you shot him in the head,
even though we don't know
for a fact that's the case
until later.
And then if that was the case,
and let's pretend everything's
fine.
If that wasn't the case, we just
remove the effect, so to speak.
Oh, you didn't lose
that health actually.
Because otherwise it
becomes too laggy.
So you need to apply
effect immediately,
ask if it happened.
And then you need
to correct later
if the game server
disagrees for some reason.
And you have a bunch of
techniques in the game server
to make sure that you
can figure this out.
Because when the game
server gets the message,
it's like 100 milliseconds ago.
So it needs to go
back and see what
happened 100 milliseconds ago.
Where were everyone?
Oh, that guy was there.
OK, you did that head
shot or you didn't.
MARK MANDEL: And you
say you also have
a variety of microservices.
Do you also spread those
around in a variety of regions?
Or do you have them centrally?
BJORN LINDBERG: We spread them
over one region in Europe.
So that's mostly what we
call the core system, which
is, like, what you log into,
where you find your friends,
where you create a clan,
where you fiddle around
with your which character
should I choose?
What game server should
a play on, et cetera,
those kind of things.
And it's not particularly
latency sensitive.
It doesn't really matter
so much if it takes
like half a second to log in.
You're going to do it
once, and then you're
going to play for an hour.
No one cares.
ROBERT MARTIN: So
these core services
can be sort of
centrally located.
It's really the game
servers that you need
to get closer to the players.
BJORN LINDBERG:
Yeah, those the ones
that we need to
spread out, yeah.
ROBERT MARTIN: Yeah,
that's interesting.
And so you mentioned
you're using nine regions.
We have about 20 regions.
What's sort of the
balance in finding
the right number of regions and
versus the number of players
that you can find to
play within those?
BJORN LINDBERG: I mean, for
finding the right regions,
you want to be
everywhere, basically.
You want to be in South
America and the United States.
And you want to be
in Africa, et cetera,
et cetera, et cetera, right?
So you want to be everywhere.
In many places,
there's not going
to be a whole lot of players
during particular hours.
Like, if you do
downtime in Australia,
it's not a whole lot of
players playing, right?
Autoscaling makes it
easier, obviously.
So finding the right
number of services
is not the problem
that we want to solve
on a daily basis, where we would
add like a stand up and say,
yesterday we ran out of
capacity in Australia.
We should probably add
one more game server.
No, we don't want to do that.
It's, like, we can automate
that relatively straightforward.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And did you have a strong
relationship with Google Cloud
when you set this up?
Did we help you out in any way?
BJORN LINDBERG: We have
Marcus [INAUDIBLE]..
And I brought in a
bunch of tech people.
So we're sitting around there.
And we're playing a game
and waiting for something
to go bad.
I don't think anything
really went bad.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's nice.
BJORN LINDBERG: Marcus is
shaking his head like, nope,
nothing went bad.
So you have everyone there.
So we have this big
war room upstairs where
we have all these monitors.
And everyone is represented, so
to speak, all the stakeholders.
So we can figure out if
something goes wrong,
you can figure
out what and where
and who should deal with it.
And usually you go to everyone.
It's like, we have this problem,
you can you see anything?
Can you go look at
your monitoring?
And say, can you
see anything weird?
Like, nope, OK.
We check around.
Ah, here's something, OK.
Dig dig.
ROBERT MARTIN: It sounds like
the launch went really well.
But this was your first
sort of cloud-native launch
with Google Cloud.
What were some of the
challenges that you
encountered in
launching the game
and how did you overcome them?
BJORN LINDBERG: From
a cloud perspective
in particular, or generally,
and from a cloud perspective,
there wasn't something that was
really worrying, so to speak.
The way we see hardware is
that OK, here's a machine.
We write everything for what you
would call commodity hardware,
like garden-variety services.
Like, we don't have a
requirement of special machines
with very expensive
database machines
with tons and tons of
memory, anything like that.
So as long as you
provide hardware,
we can usually run on it.
Game servers are a
little different.
They need to be quite large
mostly because you want to cram
in those 5,000-ish
players on them.
No not really,
there's nothing that
was particularly complicated.
There's always this little
bug you need to go find.
But usually in my software,
like most of the things
just work right.
MARK MANDEL: That just
sounds too good to be true.
BJORN LINDBERG:
Yeah, it is, kind of.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: I mean,
I'm not complaining
from the Google side.
BJORN LINDBERG: No, no, no.
I know it always sounds like
it's too good to be true.
But we did for "Division 1,"
and a lot of the technology
is the same, obviously,
because there's
no reason to go around and
reinvent it from scratch again,
right?
We just say, OK,
here's everything
we did for "Division 1."
Of course we make changes,
particularly like things,
like, we added leaderboards.
We added cloud,
new microservices.
But the model and how you
structure it around it
is the same.
We are microservices.
Here's the team doing
that feature, basically.
MARK MANDEL: But "Division 1"
wasn't run on Google Cloud.
BJORN LINDBERG: No.
MARK MANDEL: Right.
When you came over
to Google Cloud,
were there particular things
you were looking to improve on
as you came across that you
found that were possible now
that you were on Google Cloud?
BJORN LINDBERG:
Yeah, autoscaling,
automatic deployment
of services,
that's like number one, I
think, and also ease of it.
It's much easier
for us to just say,
here's the script that
runs Terraform and sets up
the environment.
It's like, boom, done.
It saves a lot of
time also when you're
doing testing because you have
all the first-party experts,
Microsoft, et cetera.
And they want to certify
the build obviously.
So they need a particular build.
And it needs to be
online, of course.
So you can set up them.
Like, here is your system that
runs this particular build,
slang for worse and so to
speak, in case someone wonders.
But here's your
particular build.
Do all your testing
as you please.
And we're going to
update it in seven days.
So we get the licensing
rights and whatever.
And they have a certain
stint where they do testing.
And same thing for localisation.
You have a bunch of guys
going in and saying,
is this is the
Spanish localization?
Great, basically.
They need a copy of
everything running
with a particular version.
And you might end up in QA,
Quality Assurance, et cetera,
that does all the
same things, right?
And you want them to be all be
online in the same environment
as live would be like.
And for a day, of course,
you're all on different builds
because why would we
have been on the same?
That would be too easy.
But you can [INAUDIBLE]
environments.
So it saves a lot of time
because when you do it
on fixed hardware, someone's
going to say, well,
this is expensive.
Can you have less?
OK, sure.
You can run the game
live on less hardware
and cut, cut, cut,
And then we end
up, oh my god, we
need to also have all
these testing environments.
Where do we put them anyway?
We want them to be the same as
much as possible, obviously,
because that's what
you're testing.
At least you want all the
configuration of everything
to be relatively the same.
So the difference between
a test environment
and the live
environment, in our case,
is generally that we
don't allow people
in unless they have certain
properties on their account.
And we basically
whitelist IP ranges
and say, these are
allowed to connect,
these studios or these people.
That's the difference.
Otherwise, it's
pretty much the same.
ROBERT MARTIN: It
sounds like the ability
to spin up environments
when you need them,
experiment with
different regions
were really kind of keys
to the success this time.
BJORN LINDBERG:
Yeah, I would say so.
You get to a point
where you basically say,
I want to test this as
live-like as possible.
And that's it.
Being able to spin
them up as you want
saves a lot of
time for everyone.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
BJORN LINDBERG:
Our core business
is not running servers.
businesses to make games.
And in a way, we want to
get away as much as possible
from the nitty-gritty details.
On the other hand,
we have a bunch
of people who are super
interested in these things.
So we like to try
to strike a balance.
It becomes interesting
for everyone.
MARK MANDEL: I'm
curious if you're
going to do this all over again,
is there anything that you
would change or do differently?
BJORN LINDBERG: No, not really.
Not from the GCP side.
We look at it from
what is the game?
What is the player experience?
If the player
experience dictates
we need to change something,
then we do change something.
And as I said earlier, we're
running on commodity hardware.
So it's unlikely that we're
going to say, oh, my god,
we need completely
different hardware.
It's like, it's just
still the same Intel
machines in the bottom running
on a virtualization layer.
And it's like, maybe
we change the specs,
like less cores, more cores,
less memory, et cetera,
that kind of thing.
But to me, that's a slider
in the UI on a web page
pretty much.
And that's kind of
what I like about it
because you don't have to make
these decisions very early.
If you do them physically,
you need to go in
and say, OK, we're going
to this kind of game.
What does it mean in
terms of hardware?
What is the hardware
profile we're looking for?
I don't have to.
It's like, yeah, how
many cores do you want?
OK, I want 16.
OK, good.
There are 16.
Go.
MARK MANDEL: Now, you
also mentioned previously
having dashboards and monitoring
and keeping this thing alive.
I mean, launch is one thing.
But keeping it alive over
a period of time, what do
look at there for a monitoring
of game servers and games
services there?
BJORN LINDBERG: So the
way it works kind of like,
first you have your
monitoring layer,
which can tell us basic
stuff about the hardware,
to a level where
you're monitor it,
like CPU consumption and
bandwidth and that kind
of stuff, which is interesting.
But in the code,
we basically have--
it's called a data sample.
It's essential a way to just
say, here's the data point,
and that can end up
in various places.
But one of them is
InfluxDB in Grafana.
And then we have Zabbix.
So what we do in InfluxDB with
Grafana is draw all the graphs.
And we know roughly what
we want to look at and.
For Zabbix, it's most
like if this ever
happens or this value ever
is lower or higher than this,
you want an alarm.
And then you sort your
alarms according to severity.
And then some of them, it's
going to send you an SMS
and say, hey, you
should probably
look at this because this
shouldn't be like this.
It's a lot of them.
MARK MANDEL: It sounds like
he use a lot of open source
monitoring tools.
Did you choose
those for a reason?
BJORN LINDBERG: We
choose them naturally.
We have basically the same stack
for "Division 1," more or less,
at least.
They're available.
There's certain problems you
don't want to bother with.
Like, you don't want to write
your own operating systems
or databases.
It just takes too much
time for a little game.
You can use open source
stuff in this case
and just be on your merry
way doing games instead.
ROBERT MARTIN: And
are you monitoring
sort of technical elements
of the system operation?
Or is it more like player
experience type of metrics?
BJORN LINDBERG: We do both.
Player experience,
generally speaking,
it's a little bit harder
because you usually
look at aggregates of data.
You need to say,
OK, I've collected
all this data about the
player experience so far.
Typical example is what
you can see, for instance--
and this is a classic example
of why in game analytics
everyone fails at level 7.
People stop playing at level 7.
Why is that?
And then you go look.
Oh, this mission that you
have to play at level 7
is too hard, for instance.
That's a typical thing.
But you cannot see it as a
blip that happens just now.
You need to look at the
entire history of the--
ROBERT MARTIN: Trend over time.
BJORN LINDBERG: Yeah,
trends over time.
And that's basically run on
a totally different system,
because we are
solving two needs.
One is I would like to
see what happens right now
Grafana dashboard, Big Graph
or Zabbix alerts telling me
what's happening.
Or we have even more
elaborate interfaces,
where I can basically go to--
Every server has to know the
web page where I can go and see
what do you think
about life right now?
Like, what's your
CP consumption?
How many file hands do
you have open, et cetera,
that kind of stuff.
While monitoring all of
the gaming experience
is usually something that you
put your data in a database.
You run an intel.
You get a report on whatever
cadence you want, basically,
as soon as you can
do it or weekly
or whatever, depending on what
area you're interested in.
So generally, those take
a little longer time.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And so that difference between
monitoring and analytics,
right?
BJORN LINDBERG: Exactly.
Generally speaking, you
can't act on it immediately
anyway because you need to do a
game, some change to the game,
right?
You need to make a new building,
a new change on the sign.
You say, OK, that guy
was too hard to defeat.
I need to tune it
down a bit, right?
And you can't do that
with knob game design
for all those ones have a
knob for every single thing.
But it's like to tune
it live, so to speak.
But it turns out to
be an impossibility
because the number
of knobs basically.
If it was, like, one
knob, you can probably
do it or 10 but not if we're
talking about literally
thousands.
I think thousands is low-ball
number for how many knobs
they would want to have
ideally to tune everything
to their liking.
ROBERT MARTIN: Yep.
So you'd need some time
to make adjustments.
BJORN LINDBERG: Yeah, and
even if you have the knob,
you might not want to
touch it because you don't
know what's going to happen.
You probably want to
run it through QA way,
right, because it's easier
to maneuver that thing
and say, oh, that's [INAUDIBLE].
And then, oh, my god,
now we have an exploit
because a certain combination
of gear and whatever,
and you end up in a situation
where just people are fooling
that boss and get all the loot.
MARK MANDEL: And game
players will definitely
work that stuff out.
BJORN LINDBERG: Oh, yeah.
ROBERT MARTIN: Yes, they will.
BJORN LINDBERG: Absolutely.
I mean, you're testing
and testing and testing.
And the number of
hours of testing
goes into product is staggering.
It's like you wouldn't
imagine it, right?
And then you go live.
And then, like, two days
later, they find an exploit.
It's like, how did
you guys find it?
OK, all you players.
You're gamers.
You're trained to that.
ROBERT MARTIN: It's the mindset.
BJORN LINDBERG: Yeah.
ROBERT MARTIN: So it's been
a great discussion about some
of the services in
GCP that you use
to launch "Division
2," Compute Engine
and a few of our other sort of
global infrastructure services.
Maybe for the next
game, what else
could Google be doing to help
support your game launches?
What other types of
services and offerings
do you think would
be most important?
BJORN LINDBERG: I think from
our perspective, or at least
my perspective,
as I said earlier,
we write a whole lot
of software ourselves.
And we don't necessarily
depend so much on services
to do things.
The problem with service
generally speaking
is they usually involve
a machine [INAUDIBLE]
to make a request.
And it's kind of
like it's a slow rate
of response kind of thing.
What I'm really interested in
is getting good open source
libraries to solve
common problems.
Like, I would like
to have an SSL
library that is understandable,
have some reasonable source
code.
And I don't need
[INAUDIBLE] 4 or Lambda 5.
I need AAS and [INAUDIBLE]
and that modern stuff, right?
That doesn't necessarily
make too much assumption
about operating environment,
doesn't necessarily
have to be Unix-like.
We also need to build for
other platforms and just
Unix-like platforms.
And you have already open
sourced a bunch of compressors
and that kind of stuff.
I like that because it's
like it builds everywhere.
I can use it everywhere.
It's readily available.
It doesn't make a big
complicated installation.
You get a library file and a
header, and that's it, done.
Build it.
Done.
And that kind of stuff
would be great to have more
of because everyone wants it.
Everyone needs it.
It's just a convenience of
having available, so to speak.
ROBERT MARTIN: So really
kind of reusable components
that lots of studios
and publishers
would all either have
to invent for themselves
or go find somewhere.
BJORN LINDBERG: We
don't have the resources
to put a bunch of people on
building a new compression
library because we really don't
have that kind of resources.
And same thing in crypto
is even worse, right?
Because even if you build your
own crypto and think it works,
it's going to be vetted for
10 years before [INAUDIBLE] it
basically.
And that kind of organization
is not available to us,
basically, because
we are relatively
small by comparison at least.
And yeah, getting a
hold of that stuff, that
would be great because you're
asking what services would
we want to use?
I say, yeah, we
like your services.
But what we would like
even more is source code.
MARK MANDEL: No, that
makes a lot of sense.
All right, well, fantastic.
Well, Bjorn, thank you
so much for spending time
with us today.
BJORN LINDBERG: Yeah,
thank you, guys.
MARK MANDEL: It's been
a really great pleasure.
BJORN LINDBERG: Thanks
for coming over.
ROBERT MARTIN: Thank
you, enjoyed it.
BJORN LINDBERG: Yeah, all right.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks
again to Bjorn
from Massive giving you
some wonderful insights
into how they build and run
their games on Google Cloud,
a great, great interview.
And thanks again to Robert
Martin as well for joining us
as a guest host
while I was traveling
through Sweden with
him, definitely
appreciate him taking the time.
So episode 200,
this is going to be
my last episode on the "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I'm not going too far.
I'm just looking
to spend some more
time on probably unsurprisingly
some gaming things.
Also, it's been
four years that I've
been working on this podcast.
And it was time to get some
new voices in and give them
some space to be
heard, for sure.
So some thanks that I think
need to be said, first of all,
thanks to all the new
hosts that are coming
on the podcast and
all the kind words
that they said at the
beginning of this episode.
That definitely
makes me feel nice.
And I'm super happy
that everyone's
having a wonderful experience.
All the new hosts are amazing.
They're all doing amazing work,
as many of you all listening
and already know.
And I expect lots of really,
really cool and interesting
episodes in the near
future and beyond.
I also want to say some
historical thanks as well.
Obviously, thanks
to Francesc Campoy
Flores for initially starting
this podcast with me.
Without you, this would
not have been possible.
I think we both helped set the
tone and helped set the content
and really just built
the foundation of this
from the ground up.
So Francesc, 200th episode
is as much kudos to you
as it is to just
about anyone else.
I'll say thanks as
well to Greg Wilson.
His support from leadership
has always been exemplary,
ever since day zero,
when Francesc and I had
this super interesting idea to
start a podcast, always just
a massive amount of
support from leadership.
So Greg, thank you
so much for that.
A huge amount of thanks
to Melanie Warrick,
who was my second
co-host on the podcast.
Melanie was, quite
frankly, a breath
of fresh air and
just amazing content
that she brought
onto the podcast.
Enjoyed my time with
you immensely and look
back on that quite
fondly and will continue
to do so for a long time.
I definitely also want to send a
shout out to all the logistical
people who work on
this behind the scenes,
[? Kristina ?] [? Fan, ?]
who's our producer,
who just manages everything
these days and is basically
the lifeblood of the podcast.
You don't see their
name show up anywhere,
but [? Kristina ?] is amazing.
And if you ever run into her
at a Next or any other event,
please give her a huge thanks
for the work that she does.
Also, the HD interactive team,
again, probably not a name
you would see.
But that team there
does all our editing,
all our content producing,
all our social work,
all our launches.
They do a phenomenal
job each and every week.
And they're just tireless
in their efforts.
They really are just an
absolutely phenomenal team.
And so my hat's off
to all of you as well.
I'm really excited about
the future of the podcast.
But I definitely don't want
to be remiss and miss out
on saying thanks
to the listeners.
It has been a delight
and a pleasure being
on this podcast
journey with everyone
who listens to the podcast.
It is hugely, hugely warming to
hear the positive experiences
that people have had
because the podcast,
from people getting jobs at
Google and other companies
because of the educational
content, people coming
to our events that we've run
simply because of the podcast,
and just many more.
It is truly just a pleasure to
join you all on this journey.
And it is definitely bittersweet
to be saying goodbye now.
So with that being
said, for the last time,
for me on the "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast,"
thank you all for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]